do you know that cyber attacks occur
every 39 seconds with an average of
2244 attacks per day this is the main
reason to keep your company safe online
for its survival and growth in today's
digital era as businesses grow the need
for cyber Security Experts will keep
increasing in 2024 and Beyond
so cyber security is a field that's
still looking for more qualified
professionals according to statista the
revenue generated in the field of cyber
security is expected to grow from
121.92 billion dollars in 2020 to about
183.14 billion dollars in 2024. the
demand for cyber security jobs has gone
up a lot in recent years by 2024 there
will be over 1 million cyber security
jobs available but will have less than
400 000 trained professionals to fill
them so cyber security is a growing
field with an estimated 11 growth in
2024 and a whopping 20 growth expected
in 2025. it's a fast moving career and
the average salary in this domain is
around 81 000 dollars
so in this video we'll explore the top
10 highest paying cyber security jobs in
2024. will delve into the career Outlook
and income potential for each of these
routes so hey everyone and welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel before we
get started with the top 10 highest
paying cyber security jobs in 2024
remember to subscribe to our Channel
because we bring the best videos for
YouTube also hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from Simply learn with
cyber crimes becoming more prevalent and
sea view it has become crucial to
address the cyber security skill Gap and
overcome the shortage of cyber Talent if
you are interested in pursuing a career
in cyber security and acquiring the
necessary skills then our postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with the MIT University is
surely the right option for you
gain expertise and defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics ethical hacking penetration
testing and other crucial domains with
this intensive program
a comprehensive program offers a
curriculum encompassing various
in-demand cyber security tools Hands-On
labs and guided practices for admission
to this postgraduate program in cyber
security candidate should have a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50
or higher marks a candidate may have a
non-programming background and
candidates with one year of experience
are preferred so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details let's start this video with
the top 10 highest paying cyber security
jobs in 2024. at number 10 we have
incident manager an incident manager is
a professional responsible for
overseeing and coordinating the response
to unexpected events or incidents within
an organization primary role involves
leading efforts to identify manage and
resolve incidents ensuring minimal
disruption and damage to the
organization's operations and systems
incident managers are typically skilled
in crisis management communication
skills and problem solving
and they work to restore normalcy as
swiftly as possible when an incident
occurs talking about the salary
according to glassdo the average salary
for an incident manager in India is
rupees 7 lakhs 54
478 per annum and in the United States
it goes around 84 502 dollars per year
with additional cash benefits
moving on to number nine we have the
computer forensics analyst a computer
forensics analyst also known as a
digital forensics analyst is a
specialized investigator in the field of
cyber security and law enforcement they
are trained to collect analyze and
preserve digital evidence from computers
mobile devices and other digital media
to support legal investigations
they work on recovering deleted
manipulated or stolen data
according to glassdo the average salary
for a computer forensics analyst in
India is rupees 9 lakh
7622 per year and in the United States
it goes around 89
956 dollars per year with additional
cash compensation at number eight we
have a malware analyst a malware analyst
identifies and examines cyber threats
such as viruses worms Bots androgens to
understand their nature they develop
malware protection tools and finally
they document the methods to avoid
malware threats their primary
responsibility is to investigate and
understand the inner workings of malware
to protect computer systems networks and
data from cyber threats
salary offered malware analyst in India
goes around rupees 7 lakh
9742 per year and in the United States
it goes around 95 909 dollars per year
with additional cash benefits at number
seven we have a database administrator
a database administrator is an
individual or role responsible for
overseeing the security of an
organization's database
their primary focus is on ensuring that
sensitive data stored in databases is
protected from unauthorized access
breaches and data theft data
administrators are vital for the smooth
functioning of any organization
talking about the salary the average
salary of a database administrator is
rupees 6 lakh 61 508 rupees per year in
India and in the United States it goes
around 105
149 dollars per year with additional
cash compensation
moving on to number six we have Cloud
security specialist because of the
increased Reliance on the cloud cloud
security Specialists are in high demand
and will remain so in the future a cloud
security specialist is a cyber security
professional who specializes in ensuring
the security of cloud computing
environments and the data and
applications hosted within them these
Specialists focus on protecting
cloud-based systems services and
infrastructure from various cyber
threats and vulnerabilities the average
salary for a cloud security specialist
is rupees 19 lakh 53 506 per year in
India and in the United States it goes
around 118
834 dollars per annum with additional
cash benefits moving on to number five
we have an application security engineer
an application security engineer
specializes in protecting computer
software applications from security
threats and vulnerabilities
their primary focus is on ensuring that
software applications are developed
deployed and maintained with robber
security measures in place
talking about the salary according to
glassdo the average salary for an
application security engineer is rupees
9 lakh 46 809 per year in India and in
the United States it goes around 134
000 per year with additional cash
compensation
at number four we have the penetration
tester a penetration tester often
referred to as an ethical hacker or a
whitehead hacker is a cyber security
professional who specializes in
assessing the security of computer
systems networks and application their
primary role is to simulate cyber
attacks on an organization's system to
identify vulnerabilities weaknesses and
the security flaws before malicious
hackers can exploit them
talking about the salary the average
salary for a senior penetration tester
is rupees 15 lakh per year in India and
in the United States it goes around 137
000 per annum with additional cash
benefits so we are here for the top
three cyber security careers in 2024. at
number three we have cyber security
engineers
a cyber security engineer also known as
a security engineer or information
security engineer is a professional
responsible for Designing implementing
and maintaining security measures and
safeguards to protect an organization's
digital assets system and data from
cyber threats and attacks
they design cyber security platforms and
also collaborate with other teams to
maintain overall security talking about
the salary figures according to glassdo
the average salary for a senior cyber
security engineer is rupees 16 lakh per
year in India and in the United States
it goes around 140
1251 dollars per annum with additional
cash compensation
moving on to number two we have security
architect a security architect is a
professional who specializes in
designing and building robber security
systems and strategies to protect
computer network systems and data from
various cyber attacks and threats they
work to create comprehensive security
Frameworks that Safeguard an
organization's digital assets and
information moving on to certifications
for security Architects to do well as a
security architect it helps to have a
certifications like com Tia Security
Plus and cissp certified information
system Security Professionals talking
about the salary figures according to
glassdo the average salary for a
security architect is rupees 20 lakh per
year in India and in the United States
it goes around 245
000 per annum with additional cash
benefits and finally at number one we
have the chief info Asian security
officer often termed as ciso a chief
information security officer is a high
level executive responsible for
overseeing an organization's information
security strategy and managing its cyber
security program the ciso plays a
critical role in safeguarding an
organization's digital assets data and
information systems from cyber threats
and ensuring the confidentiality
integrity and availability of sensitive
information
certifications for ciso to become a ciso
the preferred certifications are
certified information security manager
cism and certified information system
security professional cissp
talking about the salary figures the
average salary for a chief information
security officer is rupees 27 lakh per
year in India and in the United States
it goes around
273 thousand dollars per annum with
additional cash benefits and that's a
wrap on the top 10 highest paying cyber
security jobs in 2024. it is important
to remember that cyber security
certifications are of Paramount
importance if you want to become a cyber
security professional if you hold a good
cyber security certification then your
opportunities and your visibility
increase dramatically
on that note we present to you the cyber
security expert Masters program by
simply loan the cyber security expert
Masters program will equip you with the
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain you will
learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure including
securing data and information running
risk analysis and mitigation
architecting cloud-based security
achieving compliance and much more with
the Best in Class program
this program also includes a ceh exam
virtue the prerequisites to join this
program is to have an undergraduate
degree or a diploma and one plus year of
experience is preferred so what are you
waiting for find the course link
mentioned in the description box for
more information so let's take a minute
to hear it out from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their career
hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years old and last
year I upskill with simply learned
postgraduate program in cyber security
after working 30 years in the IIT sector
in various different profiles I'm happy
to tell you that I was able to clear and
pass my cissp and ccsp certification
exams on the first attempt after taking
the course of course I must say was
packed with practical examples it was
led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and we can call it a wrap on top 10
highest paying cyber security jobs in
2024. if you have any doubts regarding
any of the job rules we have covered in
this video then feel free to drop them
down in the comment section and a team
of experts will definitely help you
we'll see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you